(guitar music)
- [Voiceover] Dead Kevin.
- Jack.
(groaning)
- Jack, are you here?
(mumbling)
(groaning)
Huh, who is that?
- Can someone put aloe on me?
Can you guys put
aloe on my back?
(groans)
- Why can't I have a straw?
- Jack, it's cold.
(groans)
- I just wanna take a shit.
I just wanna take a shit.
(light guitar music)
- Oh no.
- No no no no no no no.
- Fuck no.
- Please. Why are
you doing this?
Jack, get him. Get him!
- Shit, shit, ow,
I'm coming for you sucker!
- Rough week.
(guitar music)
- Dear diary, what a
hellish week it's been.
I wish more people
would subscribe
and like our YouTube
page, Dead Kevin Sketch.
I also wish they'd tell stories
about the roughest
week they had.
- Jack shut up man.
- Jesus Christ.